the jurogan experience can i smoke a
cigarette in here
the people that uh i'm quitting when the
special come out mom
do you want a um cigar no no no last
time i did that [ __ ] it [ __ ] me up
cigars [ __ ] you up how so
it just made my [ __ ] all dry i mean this
ain't healthy but i'm an addict it's
definitely not help i'm just making
excuses how often do you smoke them
cigarettes yeah
god damn
well probably you know it's it it
changes when i'm doing comedy when i'm
when i'm performing you pref you smoking
more yeah interesting i smoke more when
i'm at the comedy store and [ __ ]
because everybody else is doing it it's
social no no one else does it no one
very few kind of [ __ ] like most
people like no this is the era of the
healthy comics ah those [ __ ]
mm-hmm they're judging you judgers
goddamn judgy [ __ ]
my special comes out today i'm done
that's it you're done i told her i told
her when it comes out i'm done and what
are you going to do to replace it you're
going to do gum you're going to do
the the [ __ ] that you put in your mouth
you know
i was hanging out with shaub at
schultz's wedding and he takes those
little dip pouches shoves in his mouth
he grabbed three of those [ __ ]
and stuck him inside his cheek like a
squirrel and i go what do you do and he
goes i'm an addict because i'm a
straight addict i can't do it man the
[ __ ] so just so one time when i was a
when i was deployed
we we had our little
this was my second appointment so by
this time we had like more comforts and
[ __ ] and we had our little six
a little 12 by six can or whatever but
my can so there's
there's six marines sleeping in one of
these things
but my can had we we had negotiated with
the locals and we had a tv
we had an xbox and we had a little
makeshift couch that we had built and
like made comfortable so everybody would
come in our room and like watch the
sopranos
or played or coming out cannon and all
that [ __ ] and this one [ __ ] i
can't remember his name
anyway this son of a [ __ ] had this
weird habit of leaving his dip bottles
every [ __ ] way
right oh no yeah and one day and you
know one day i'm sitting there i'm
drinking my [ __ ] and i put it down by my
feet and i reach back down and i grab it
not looking
mouth full of dip spit
yeah it took three people to pull me off
that [ __ ] it wasn't fair to be
mad at him for real
for not paying attention but but um i
can it's you know you have those events
where you can't control yourself you
relive them like every time i think
about it i can taste it
and i just i could never dip i could
never dip and i'm still mad about it
i've dipped it it um it definitely gives
you a nice little head rush but not as
good as cigarettes cigarettes give you
the best head rush
yeah it's like a whoo
but um i love a cigarette before i go on
stage i don't know how i'm gonna replace
that
like right before you try to use a jewel
or something like that
i don't know
that doesn't work good enough
no i think you just have to stop like
i started um
i had this book called the easy way to
stop smoking
and everybody that i've got to read the
book they've stopped
and then but i've never finished it
what does it tell you to do
it's it's
so the premise of it is basically like
they instead of
telling you the reasons you shouldn't
smoke they attack the reasons why you
say you smoke like all the reasons
people give and they show you that
they're just excuses that you're just as
much of an addict as a crackhead or
that doesn't help you
i think what helps people is uh things
like ibogaine ibogaine um
mushroom trips things like that yeah oh
yeah i know a lot of people that uh my
buddy that um actually he just left
he moved down here actually um
mitch
i can't remember mitch's last name god
damn it
anyway he quit
after a mushroom trip
he was like he did shrooms and was like
nah i was just done yeah yeah
well you start thinking about what you
could be doing to your body you know
what what could be happening inside of
your body yeah so maybe maybe i just
need a picture of a tumor
you just hang over a health scare a
little bit of health well i've had
enough of those
that doesn't stop people really no
no cigarettes there's people that's
these people that's dying in the
hospital now that's still sneaking out
the smoke cigarettes yeah but that's
just cause they know they're dying no
i'd rather just take the cigarette now
other than like die and not enjoy a
cigarette because you're already dying
so you need so you said the type of
health scare where they like look stop
you stop now yeah you'll be okay but if
you don't stop now yeah maybe one of
those something's got to like they got
to show you your lungs or you see the
blackness like the tar and all the
[ __ ] decay
have you seen like a smoker's lung when
they pull it out and then they put it
next to a healthy person's song on an
autopsy table yeah and it looks it's
wild it's yeah go see if you can find a
video they they're or a photo there's
they do autopsies of these people who
die lung cancer and you know lifetime
cigarette smokers and they're [ __ ]
their their lungs
they they look like they're just covered
look at that look at that [ __ ] lung
look at the lung jerky look at that one
the the black lungs of a chain smoker
the one the upper left click on that
look at that that is insane man
that's so insane
that looks like someone oh my god look
at that next to a regular lung
that is so wild one lung is like orangy
reddish pink
and the other one is literally black and
white like white tissue and black tissue
[ __ ] wild man that is wild
terrible as i goddamn it smoke myself
this is like that one up there that one
the second down right below that look at
that oh jesus christ look at they're all
shriveled this is like showing me stool
samples while i'm eating
yeah but that's if i'm still hungry i'll
still eat
really you could just put power through
i don't know i was on fear factor it's
not real this is a computer
oh it's computer generation oh okay oh
that's still pretty accurate probably
accurate but the one next to it is real
that's real man what's wrong with that
one down there the one that looks like
this like it has cheese on it
which one's that the one in the middle
oh it's pus what is that
pulmonary pathology
good god it's [ __ ] up because like the
thing that scares people the most is not
being able to breathe
you know that's what's interesting it's
like that feeling that you can't breathe
is terrifying to people that's why
drowning is so terrifying to people but
they say that the last days of a
person's life when they're dying of lung
cancer is like drowning
it's like you you can't breathe and
you're you're gasping for air and it's
like your lungs are filling up with
fluid you can't get any oxygen in there
because all the sores are like popping
look yeah as you tap and take another
hit
you went through that cigarette quick
too
oh how many do you smoke a day
oh
it varies
but a pack at the most a pack
yeah it's a lot
what does it pack 16 how many is in
there 20 20.
it's actually perfectly formulated for
you to smoke all day oh so if you start
early and keep going it's like the rate
that like the nicotine
gets out of your system yeah and it's
supposed to be like every 40 minutes or
something like that and so the sick you
have just enough cigarettes to smoke all
day long
you know what's interesting like
nicotine is actually a medicine nicotine
itself um i think it's got heart
uh applications see it like nicotine for
heart
nicotine
they use it to treat [ __ ] nicotine by
itself is not bad which sounds so crazy
and it's also um a nootropic
meaning like uh it stimulates cognitive
function
like nicotine does stimulate it's one
thing stephen king said in his book
on writing is that quitting cigarettes
was very hard for him because it's like
his writing suffered a little bit it's
harder for him to write
oh dude
because there's something about the
cigarette that like it fires up the
synapses it fires up the brain
and then the writing would come smoother
yeah i don't know i don't know because
i've
i've smoked all the time i've been doing
comedy and writing
so a man that would be that would be
like torture like if i couldn't if the
ideas came to me less
yeah i think that's what what he was
saying but i think you can you could
probably get around that with other
stuff